bonjour à tous si vous vous intéressez
aux nouvelles technologies et tout
particulièrement à la réalité virtuelle
et est la réalité augmentée vous allez
être satisfait j'ai pu tester en
avant-première à l'ifa de berlin
la solution windows mme x reality qui
regroupe deux côtés la réalité virtuelle
et de l'autre côté la réalité augmentée
si vous ne me connaissez pas vos palmes
et chevreux ma chaîne parle de high tech
du tout les premiers d'affluence de tous
les produits qui vous aideront à réussir
votre vie numérique
en parallèle je donne aussi des conseils
pour progresser sur youtube
justement en parlant de stratégie
numérique et de vie numérique
j'ai pu tester la réalité virtuelle et
la réalité augmentée d'un côté la
réalité virtuelle avec notamment les
casques de hp le côté est la réalité
augmentée avec le casque all all ends de
microsoft alors windows migs reality
qu'est ce que c'est réellement c'est
d'un côté de la réalité virtuelle au
travers de différents casque qui nous
permettra effectivement différentes
applications du jc on en parlera dans
quelques instants et de l'autre côté de
la réalité augmentée c'est à dire
superposer des choses qui n'existent pas
de choses virtuelles directement à la
réalité concernant la réalité virtuelle
vous n'avez pas besoin d'avoir une
grande configuration de votre pièce
vous n'avez pas besoin de poser une
caméra qui va vous filmez pour
reconnaître votre emplacement
le casque fait tout seul grâce au
système tracking inside out de microsoft
vous avez des capteurs directement dans
votre caste est directement intégrée qui
reconnaissent notre position qui sont en
gros capables si vous voulez de
connaître votre pièce par exemple vous
allez pas vous cogner contre un mur vous
n'allez pas vous à souper normalement
vous êtes protégé tout devrait plutôt
bien se passer de ce côté là il vous
suffit tout simplement de
minutes pour pouvoir installer votre
système votre casque et pouvoir en
profiter vous le câble et un ordinateur
qui tourne sous windows 10 et uniquement
sur windows 10 avec un ordinateur
compatible avec le windows mixte reality
alors ça c'est le côté réalité virtuelle
de l'autre côté il existe le casque
microsoft online ce qui vous permet
d'avoir de la réalité augmentée
alors pour l'avoir essayé vous avez deux
petits écrans qui vient de se
positionner juste devant vos yeux
bien évidemment on voit par transparence
donc on voit sa pièce et vous avez comme
un espèce d'hologrammes qui vient se
superposer à la réalité et c'est assez
bluffant
parce que de ce que j'ai pu essayer g si
vous voulez comme un espèce de tôle au g
qu'il faisait signe d'aller vers lui
j'avance et en avançant sa position
restait exactement la même en gros c'est
comme si la pièce avait été scanné est
programmé pour être exactement la
position accueil devait se situer ce
d'hologrammes donc quand j'avance et un
moment il décalé et je le suivais donc
j'ai suivi tout un trajet autour de lui
c'était très très nette très précis est
assez intéressant alors le petit bémol
du casco lawless je sais pas si je vais
bien positionné sur ma tête mais je
trouve que c'était pas hyper évident
pour pouvoir effectivement avoir une
vision complètement optimales alors
probablement parce que je l'essayé lors
d'un salon je n'ai pas forcément bien
positionné sur ma tête mais en tout cas
le rendu
vraiment bluffant très intéressant
d'avoir de la réalité augmentée en se
passant effectivement d'un smartphone
d'une tablette donc ça s'est vraiment
bien
alors qu'est ce que vous allez devoir
faire avec ces solutions alors il ya
d'un côté une solution grand public
c'est la réalité virtuelle avec les
différents au casque dont je vous
parlais en quelques instants
et puis d'un autre côté un système ne
dit pas plus professionnel avec le
casque au lawrence de microsoft il faut
savoir que kas polonaise de microsoft
coûte pas moins de 3000 $ donc il n'est
pas forcément adapté à tout le monde
mais en tout cas il ya déjà des sociétés
comme areva qui devrait l'utiliser dans
ses centrales nucléaires pour tous les
travaux de maintenance est différent
tous été aussi qui devrait l'utiliser
pour la conception donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui va se démocratiser
développer de plus en plus pour les
professionnels ça on le met de côté en
ce qui nous concerne c'est plutôt le
côté grand public avec elle la réalité
virtuelle
on va pouvoir utiliser pour différentes
applications du jeu du voyage de la
vidéo à 360 des événements également
pour de la création et pour du partage
où la rencontre sociale point de vue
matériel comme je le disais il existe
actuellement six casques qui sont
compatibles windows l'icsg reality il y
a un casque
acer un casque hp asus dell lenovo est
le tout dernier venu le cast samsung
pour ma part j'utilise et le casque hp
avec un casque audio jbl le casque hp ou
399 euros il reste quand même
relativement abordable pour un casque de
réalité virtuelle vous propose une
révolution en 2008 180 par 1440 pixels
c'est bien évidemment un écran lcd avec
un champ de vision jusqu'à 105 degrés
côté très intéressant qu'on va trouver
avec cette solution windows mix de
reality c'est à dire que lorsque vous
avez votre caste et groupe bouger la
tête le casque reconnaît vous
mouvements les interprète et vous les
retranscrit directement dans votre vidéo
donc c'est encore plus immersif que les
différentes solutions qu'on peut trouver
sur le marché pour l'utiliser il vous
faut forcément votre casse mais vous
faut également aussi deux contrôleurs
que vous pouvez acheter chez microsoft
vous prenez tout ça vous le branchez
avec un port hdmi et un port usb
directement sur votre ordinateur qui
bien sûr sera compatible et qui tournera
sous windows 10 et le tour sera joué
c'est très facile de prise en main et
vous vous en mettez pas pour la
configuration
la vraie différence si vous voulez par
rapport aux solutions que l'on peut
trouver sur celle de sony sur la
playstation 4 c'est que vous n'avez pas
besoin d'avoir une petite caméra qu'il
avoue filmé comme je vous le disais tout
est intégré dans le cast vous avez deux
petites caméras de chaque côté vous
permettent à priori de scan des écueil
votre position donc c'est vrai que c'est
pratique ça évite d'investir en plus sur
cette caméra à l'installation de plus
facile à faire
il ya énormément davantage autour de
cette solution là côté jeu côté
applications vous profiter du catalogue
steam vert que vous pouvez trouver sur
la solution acheter ces vagues qui fait
que vous avez quand même déjà un
catalogue préexistants avec de nombreux
jeux et de nombreuses applications vous
pourrez utiliser ça c'est quand même
plutôt sympa il faut savoir que
microsoft a vraiment ouvert le l'aspect
matériel et aussi logiciels à de
nombreux éditeurs pour pouvoir
agrémenter et avoir beaucoup plus de jeu
beaucoup plus d'application qui seront
vraiment très sympa à utiliser donc
c'est quelque chose qui va se
démocratiser et se développer dans les
années à venir tout de suite vous partez
s'il vous plaît sur une solution qui est
quand même encore un petit peu un petit
peu light en termes d'applications en
termes de choses qu'on pouvait faire
avec mais c'est des choses qui vont
vraiment se développer dans les années à
venir
on n'en est qu'au début de la réalité
virtuelle autre chose qui est très
intéressant c'est le côté social
microsoft a racheté le réseau social à
l'espace vert qui était pas très très
loin de déposer le bilan et cette
solution permet via votre caste de
pouvoir communiquer avec d'autres
personnes qui sont équipés de la même
manière au travers d'un avatar virtuel
alors ça ça va être très intéressant ça
va se développer énormément dans les
années à venir
déjà pour
communiquez avec vos amis mais aussi
pour du travail à distance ça permettra
à lorsque vous travaillez de chez vous
où vous avez des collègues qui
travaillent dans à l'étranger ou dans
d'autres villes où vous le palais au
bureau de travailler directement avec
eux en réalité virtuelle comme si vous y
étiez là on va vraiment qu'il ya un vrai
pas qui est fait en avant pour aller
d'un côté la réalité virtuelle avec les
appliquer sur ce qu'on ne connaît et le
côté social
donc ça va devenir vraiment de plus en
plus intéressants comme je le disais
j'ai essayé le casque lors de l'ifa à
berlin
et j'ai trouvé ça vraiment super
intéressant alors j'avais déjà essayé
plusieurs casques de réalité virtuelle
j'ai essayé il ya plus d'un an lors de
sa présentation avant sa sortie le
casque de sony pour la ps4
j'avais trouvé ça vraiment bien très
très intéressant je n'avais jamais
essayé avant l'année dernière de casques
de réalité virtuelle et j'avais trouvé
le système vraiment bluffant là je
trouve qu'avec celui ci on va encore un
petit peu plus loin on va encore un peu
plus loin au niveau du réalisme au
niveau du mouvement
c'est vraiment encore plus immersif pour
ma part j'ai joué un jeu acheté des
espèces de dessau de l'espace qui venait
j'avais d'un côté un bouclier de l'autre
côté
bon ça ne relève non pas sabre laser que
je vous dise n'importe quoi j'avais mon
fusil laser
je ne protégerai je tire et le mouvement
était vraiment faim extrêmement bien
connu est ce qui est sympa c'est que
lorsqu'on va changer de jeu
on va changer d'armes de typologie dame
les boutons sont assez facile de prise
en main je trouvais ça très sympa je
pense qu'on peut encore aller plus loin
en termes de joypad mais là c'était
vraiment très très agréable et il faut
reconnaître que pour l'utilisation et
est ce que j'en ai fait je les trouvais
ça vraiment bien
très immersif on oublie qu'on est dans
un salon où j'ai oublié complètement que
j'étais effectivement l'ordre dans un
grand salon alors avec plein de gens
autour de moi et je m'éclate et avec mon
jeu ajoutait les vaisseaux
extraterrestres tous les côtés ça s'est
vraiment bien et surtout le côté le côté
immersif avec le mouvement qui est
vraiment bien connu c'est très précis
j'ai trouvé ça vraiment super agréable
ou windows mixte reality sera disponible
à partir du 17 octobre 2017 sur le
marché français vous allez pouvoir
l'acheter exactement le même jour la
sortie de halo en vr d'autre chose qui
va être disponible très rapidement
pas forcément cher je vous disais les
cas ce qu'on nous avons tourné ou
350-400 peut-être 500 euros pour le plus
cher le plus cher ce sera le nouveau
casque de samsung le samsung odyssey
avec un écran amoled et des haut
parleurs à kg directement inclus vous
trouvez un casque hp pour 399 euros vous
achetez les contrôleurs j'ai pas encore
le prix à l'heure actuelle mais je pense
pas que ça ait cherché donc bien très
très très loin peut-être 70 80 euros
vous le branchez sur votre machine tout
le monde est déjà un casque audio dont
vous branchez votre casque de deux haut
parleurs de votre smartphone ou autre
directement dessus et avec un ordinateur
assez récente et tronçon windows 10 et
le tour est joué
ça tourne vous pouvez faire plein de
choses avec donc en termes
d'investissement s'est pas non plus
extrêmement vague mais pour autant
est-ce qu'on doit l'acheter maintenant
est ce qu'il ya une vraie utilité alors
je suis toujours partagé parce que moi
j'ai vraiment essayé plusieurs fois de
la réalité virtuelle
j'ai trouvé ça juste top j'ai adoré ça
le côté immersif les jeux le fait d'être
vraiment dedans
il n'y a pas à dire c'est génial mais je
reste quand même un peu sur ma faim
parce que aujourd'hui les jeux sont
assez sommaires alors effectivement vous
avez un minecraft si vous êtes un très
grand pagne de minecraft vous allez
pouvoir y jouer
virtuel pourquoi pas mais le catalogue
est un petit peu restreint alors est ce
que ça vaut le coup d'investir une telle
somme même si je n'ai pas sur des
budgets monstrueux vous êtes sur un
idiot dans le tour je pense des 500
euros vous avez vos contrôleurs votre
casque de l'or vous avez une machine qui
est compatible
ça roule mais est ce que ça vaut le coup
de s'y mettre aujourd'hui je suis un peu
un peu j'ai un peu partagé je ne suis
pas sûr que tout de suite ça vaille le
coup d'investir sur la réalité virtuelle
parce que les éditeurs ne sont pas
encore présents parce que les jeux la
grande masse de jeux ne sont pas encore
présents par contre quelque chose qui va
se développer énormément dans les années
à venir
la réalité virtuelle va devenir
complètement incontournable et tant
mieux parce que fondamentalement je
trouve que le concept est génial le côté
immersif le côté social
c'est juste extraordinaire dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez ce que vous
envisageriez d'acheter une solution
comme celle là est ce que vous avez un
windows 10 est-ce que vous en aviez
acheté un ordinateur compatible windows
unix de reality est ce que vous êtes un
grand fan de la réalité virtuelle voire
de la réalité augmentée est ce que vous
avez déjà eu l'occasion d'essayer des
casques de réalité virtuelle et
d'oreilles d'augmenter si oui lesquels
mark et moi tout ça en commentaire on en
discute ensemble vous invite à vous
abonner à la chaîne parce qu'il y aura
toujours plus de contenu sur les
nouvelles technologies
vous pouvez l'écouter sur twitter @
monsieur greu et poser toutes vos
questions avec le hashtag à ce monsieur
grue quant à moi je vous dis à très
bientôt d'ici là portez vous bien soyez
sages et restez connectés salut